hey guys it's just Eid and today I am so
excited because we are in the bathroom
doing a very special unboxing of this
right here
this is the naked 3d body scanner now it
sounds a little scandalous but I think
one of the most important things to keep
in mind is when you are on some sort of
fitness journey whether you're trying to
lose weight build muscle being able to
take all of your measurements into
account just not weight is something
that is very very important so with this
you're gonna be able to get a very
extremely accurate representation of
your current body and track your
progress just using your phone okay
should we get started Jen yeah oh boy
this is something that has been in
development since 2015 and guess what
pre-orders are finally shipping and
we're gonna be unboxing one right now
please download the naked app before
unboxing I'd already didn't follow the
instructions
[Music]
this is the mirror portion of this whole
contraption
so these run about $1,300 shipping is
$100 it looks like we have several
pieces here but it doesn't look like
installation is gonna be very difficult
[Music]
cut away
I am dusting the floor first of all this
is packaged very nice whoa this looks
nice this is something that I wish that
I would have had back I guess probably
the end of February I am NOT proud of it
but I really didn't work out for about
two years it was probably in the
absolute worst shape of my life
Jenna can definitely vouch for that
because the first type that we went on I
thought I was dying I actually thought I
was having a heart attack I was like
looking at my Apple watch and I was like
don't think I'm well so I am still in
the early stages of my fitness journey
here so this is gonna be cool to kind of
track my current progress the progress
that I have previous I was using one of
the regular Wi-Fi skills so I have that
data but I'm not sure how accurate that
is because those are really only able to
track your weights they say that they
can kind of take into account like your
body mass but I'm not sure how that all
works what else is in here
carpet feet so it looks like you can use
this on different types of floors Wow is
this heavy so this is why it's so heavy
holy moly I'd say this is about 15
pounds carpet feet these are a little
carpet feet I'm not gonna be putting
this on carpet this looks so good so
this is why it tells you to download the
app before you unbox it I've got that
one it's telling you not to set it up by
the shower and guess what I have done
I'm not gonna be leaving you dear but
this is for the sake of the demo I do
have a next to the shower but this is
something that you are not supposed to
do
it says the moisture can damage naked
sensors so this for the sake of this
video is set up here I will be moving it
we're to where I've left off now I've
learned all the things that I've done
wrong mmm definitely download the app
before you open the box doing what I was
supposed to do the first time this is
very well designed like really cool so
with the intel x86 processor four gigs
of ram and the intel realsense 3d depth
cameras this gives you enough power to
give you some very high resolution 3d
scans of your body oh look you charged
the scale through the mirror there's
USBC at the bottom didn't even know that
was under there please make sure the mir
and USB are connected okay it is this
will take about ten minutes please make
sure your scanner and scale are
connected do I need to stay here no
you're free to roam about your home
alright we're gonna go I don't know I'll
press it here and watch it it's been
updated we didn't do anything since I'm
plugging on store the charging table
Congrats gonna go take you for a scan
all right oh oh this Clos geez you're
covered I know
here I gotta pull my hair up okay I'm
gonna pull up pull my hair up but I'm
not gonna take my clothes off yet it's
not gonna be the best scan but it's
gonna be the test on the next step a red
laser will shine down from the mirror so
move the scale so the laser hits the
mark on the scale
no clerking way this is so crazy
here I was trying to measure to make
sure I had it perfectly in line position
the scale marker in the middle of your
feet step on you have six seconds okay
don't move or talk
[Music]
I can't okay checking your skin
step off but don't touch the scale for
three seconds says there's a lot
happening behind the scenes every scan
is first processed in the mirror and
then upload to the naked cloud and then
download it onto your phone the depth
sensors capture four gigabytes of raw
data that must be compiled in the mirror
here's my body with all my clothes on
you can go in and check your
measurements my left arm my right arm oh
this is a lot of information so this is
my first skin with clothes on oh my gosh
look at that hair I mean it picks up
every little crease in the clothing I
can't even imagine what's gonna pick up
on the actual body here's all the views
this is not oh my gosh okay now I need
to find something to wear and scan my
actual body I'm sorry that you have to
witness this Jenna
so now it's time to do the naked scan
sort of naked not too excited about this
but we're gonna do it and see what
happens this is so detailed points oh
look at this even tag good day bad day
diet special event so this does really
give you sort of an extreme accurate
representation of where you started and
where you are currently what I really
love about this is you're comparing
yourself to yourself everybody is
different people gain and lose weight
differently people gain muscle fast a
trendy so comparing yourself to someone
else is really not a very very
comparison with this comparing yourself
to yourself is one of the best ways to
be able to track their fitness goals let
me know what you guys do on fitness
activities is it hiking is it running is
doing something else really cool let me
know I would love to hear
yes but that I think I'm gonna go put
this somewhere where it's not next to
the shower and that's it I'm gonna try
think I'll see you later
Jenna do you want to look at me yeah
[Music]